starting off this hour is Shaun in
California hey Shaun welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys it's great to talk
to you
YouTube quick good question so I have
seven kids I'm in here in LA I have no
debt except in my house I have a pension
but realized I'd probably need to be
doing more than that and I I'm going to
be in Herring about 200k not sure what I
should be doing okay how old are you I'm
45 and you don't work I do work oh yeah
I have a pension and I didn't understand
a pension no additional oh you mean for
retirement you that okay yeah that's
good man this guy's retired with seven
kids at 45 okay
not quite huh all right so cool what's
your household income about 135 good
good for you okay well where you where
we would say you are in the baby steps
is make sure you have your emergency
fund fully funded three to six months of
expenses that's baby step three I
suspect you've already done that correct
okay well we've had that as I'm married
good and then baby step four as we put
pension aside you put 15% of your income
into retirement that's what we're doing
and that's what's not there now that
needs to be in the budget baby step five
is starting to say four kids college and
man we got a big hill to climb there and
and then if you find any money after
that I would use it to pay off your home
if I'm in your shoes I got this 200k
coming in that's 30k a kid they're not
doing the college thing most on the
going into trade the firemen and police
okay so I'm trying to I'm trying to
compare for that like do I pay the house
off in the next two years so I owe 235
on it I'd be nice dump again yeah you
could know you could dump the 200 on
that and then knock out that other 35
pretty quick and then
cash flow whatever you needed to do on
kids education so should I wait till I
retire I paid the house up and then do
basically my entire house payment in two
I'll be putting 15% of your income into
retirement I take your 200k inheritance
and throw it at the house debt leaving
only 35 there and then I would knock
that 35 out very very quickly as soon as
that's knocked out you are on baby steps
seven at that point which is build
wealth and give or give with outrageous
generosity but the bottom line is is
you're at that point you'll have a
hundred thirty five thousand our income
to save for retirement and to take care
of whatever education your seven kids
whatever you need to do with that
whatever you need to save for and invest
for on that and that gives you the
margin and the room to do that
so you've done a really good job shown